die gut aus an etwas glaubt net bekommen
beim ein video ja vor einer woche oder
so kann mir mein video zehn cent von
mädchen die jungs hatten und das
ziemlich gut bei euch angekommen und ich
hab euch ja dazu aufgefordert schreibt
mir doch mal in die kommentare
welche jungs trend fast über alles und
jetzt wirklich komplett übertrieben ich
doch unter dem video sind über 4000
kommentare also erstmal danke dafür ich
hatte eine sehr große auswahl und
witzige sachen so auf die ich selber
eigentlich auch hätte kommen können zum
teil aber bin ich nicht und deswegen
habe ich ihr euch da draußen bewegen mit
deswegen ich will eigentlich heute
überhaupt gar nicht lange lagern aber
ich muss mal kurz noch etwas länger
lagern also vielleicht recht sekunden
ich halt nicht kurs erstmal dass wir
nicht wenn ihr bock habt auf diesem pfad
zehn mädchen und jungs lieben hat man
dann nach oben da ich mit sagen bei 13
1207 reflex machen wir das und als
zweite sache noch ganz gut ich habe
jetzt formen instagram account etwas
umzustrukturieren der kommerz verein
noch so bilde wie früher nicht so ganz
professionell einfach mal hier im zelt
wieder ein spiegel sieht da man bild im
handygeschäft oder so aber es kommen
jetzt auch wirklich sehr sehr viele
professionelle bilder mit coolen outfits
oder dorf und deswegen kann ich euch nur
an verträgen ich würde mich sehr freuen
wenn ihr einfach mal vorbeischauen würde
ich habe da eben auch schon bei nefs
bild was du in die richtige richtung
oder in die neue richtung geht
gepolstertes comment natürlich nicht nur
so professionellere bilder hin und
wieder dann auch mal ein wie früher aber
zum teil hat schon und ich hoffe ihr
freut euch darüber also ich sehe gegen
diverse auch du ja richtig geile bilder
wo ein bisschen bearbeitung hinter
steckt und so und ich hoffe das kommt
gut an so zeigt es auf jeden fall mag
ich heißt alex in der video beschreibung
verlinkt und vielleicht auch jemand kurz
eingeblendet butler kurzes video auf
stopp geht raus lassen voller dar wenn
ihr bock habt oder nike auf dem neuen
bild besser gefällt dann will ich das ja
und jetzt fangen wir an mit dem video so
der erste kommentar von sarah und die
schreibt ich hasse es wenn jungs e mails
keine haare haben aber immer kämpft
tragen meine meinung
ja man meine haare war das ding ist mich
hinein auch welche cap feilt voll gut
meint dass sie die fresse du sie nicht
gut aus guckt euch das mal genauer an
guck mal das tor für die ohren stehen
immer ein bisschen ab die schönste in
interviews mit ja sarah ich kenne ja
natürlich erst mal recht geben aber sich
auch dazu sagen kann man hat junge
genauso wie mädchen du manchmal das
gefühl meine haare richtig weiß auch
wenn andere vielleicht sagen ey deine
haare sind übels geil aus und dann setzt
man halt meine cap also ich trag welche
tabs ich grad an hatte ich gar nicht
sondern nur diese trucker kennt ihr
wahrscheinlich habe ich ab und zu mal
auf heute wahrscheinlich relativ
zufrieden mit meinem hund der nächste
kommentar kommt von letizia und wie
schreibt ich hatte diese
hochgekrempelten hosen und dann diese
taten knöchel das passt einfach nicht
und wie schwul aus beharrte knöchel den
schulausschuss nicht erwartet egal was
das angeht ich bin zwar kein mädchen
aber ich sehe dass 100 prozent genauso
ich versteh ich draußen 5 -5 grad und
jung aber zum teil auch nicht sein dass
nutzer aufzugeben es gibt viele mädchen
die an diese superstars an dazu kommt
auch noch und auch noch hoch
gekrempelten hosen hier unten sodass man
halt die kirche sieht bei minus fünf
grad
da hat man ja auch wächst der verstand
auch ich verstehe nicht warum er das
macht ich finde es sie bei manchen jungs
ganz cool aus so wenn man hätte dieser
finde ich ist mein geschmack aber
manchmal doch einfach total behämmert
aus allgemein style ist auf jeden fall
nicht ich will jetzt auch gar nicht mehr
dazu sagen
jedem das seine aber wenigstens im
winter ihr werdet doch kein kommentar
jungs die t-shirts kleider tragen die an
so über den arsch und fakten zu den
kniekehlen gehen täglich oder mit davon
übereinander oder löcherigen klamotten
oder ja ja bla bla also das wird den
tigers das kann ich jetzt war ich
verstehen ich verstehe da habe ich die
leute die kommen dann wirklich und haben
dann extra so genau heute weist auch
dann titel an
was einfach los bis zum krieg hin geht
mir extra für dieses video haben ja ganz
auch zu den angezogen
hey leute das ist auf ihr zu lange oder
hier und da noch der wurde dazu mit
löchern
das ist überhaupt nicht
wie man läuft tragen könne ich keine
ahnung nur die nicole schreibt dieser
trend mit den roten schuhen hält gar
nicht was meistens ja keine leones
spaßig auf ein paar rote schuhe und ich
find rote schuhe mittlerweile so
unfassbar hässlichen auf jeden fall
viele durch meine mit man gegen welche
geschäfte gehen 21 oder sonstwas und
noch große schuhe achten die sind alle
reduziert doch 940 euro von 130 oder
sogar die will keiner mehr haben aber
ich bin ja sonnenkraft und wetter passt
auf in drei monaten mache ich die wieder
im wenn der sommer kommt machen wir
weiter mit folgendem kommentar zu enge
hosen er war dazu also es gibt einige
skinny jeans sind ja ein bisschen enger
so etwas enger und dann gibt es doch mal
skinny jeans ins gegen komplett eng wind
und die finde ich auch kommt die die
finger fast auf ihnen ergibt würde für
mich auch natürlich jedem das seine
aber ich finds xvi genauso könnte dann
auch sagen dass holen wie vor weit sind
auch hässlich sind aber die sind ja eh
nicht mehr so im trend setting fire ich
zurzeit auf jeden fall solche hosen die
sind halt relativ also ein bisschen
enger geschnitten und haben jetzt ein
bündel bändchen keine ahnung wie das
heißt und ich finde kann man auf jeden
fall gut
sonst geht gar nicht so was finde ich
sowieso immer noch drin steht für das
ganz gepasst
viele jungs die ihre haare blond ferne
ist einfach contract schwul
ich finde es eigentlich gar nicht
schlimm seine haare blond gefärbt mich
mein wenn man schön finde das problem
beim einen blonden haaren waren die
waren ja irgendwie dann plötzlich ein
bisschen gelb also ich finde meine haare
gerade okay aber wenn die lang sind
danach ihr auf jeden fall wieder nicht
blind sondern im sommer ich habe da
schon eine neue idee mal sehen wir dann
reagiert und wie ging gar nicht
heute kommt bei hier das sind die v3 nie
irgendwas keine ich kenne mich damit
nicht aus ich habe die einfach mehr
gekauft weil ich dachte er kommen die
kaufte die und verkauft die dann aber
dann war nie da
und erst habe ich gedacht ich bin auf
jeden fall ein bisschen aussehen bot
aber mittlerweile finde ich die echt
geil
nur ich will eigentlich gar nicht so
damit rausgehen weil ich fühle mich
damit immer unwohl wenn ich draußen
rumlaufen
weil an der gucken auf die schuhe hast
wirklich so wenn man in der großstadt
geht und schuppen geht alle gucken auf
deine schuhe man sieht wirklich so
gruppen von 13 jährigen 14-jährigen
teenagern und die gucken auf deine
schuhe und dann gucken wir in meinen
geschichten sagt das von youtube channel
also das kam auch schon ab 50 vorbei ist
sie natürlich auch wieder
geschmackssache und jetzt bringe ich
erst mal ein schluck von meinem monster
irgendwie hab ich übrigens immer noch
seit meinem letzten video und ich hab
den mit monster energy drink verwechselt
ich wollte mein letztes video also mein
neues formaten nicht gesehen habe dass
auf jeden fall mal in der video
beschreibung verlinkt das auf jeden fall
nach diesem video noch ab schmeckt auch
gar nicht so schlimm
johanna schreib ich hatte sven jung
überall hin schnell getrocknet nach wird
das heißt ein bisschen eklig mit ja er
war bei uns war das auch eine zeit lang
so schlimm ich glaub da war ich so 14.15
oder so und alle haben durch die
nirgendwohin gerockt freund im freibad
die laufen darüber immer eine wiese und
du bist auch über die wiese gelaufen und
als dann auf dem platz war
weil deine füße folgend verschiedenen
flecken gehört die folglich an war aber
auch eklig und so ungesagt kann man das
jetzt beschreiben die nacht ich hasse es
wenn jungs einfach nett bilder stecken
die man nicht sehen will
das ist jetzt eigentlich kein trend
obwohl vettel sondern trento schickt man
news ich hab da war schon so krank es
durch gehört was die jungs so mädchen
schicken so einfach wird wo ich mir
denke ich würde mich das gar nicht mein
ein screenshot einfach das bild anders
ticken
du bist ja ich will jetzt auch gar nicht
weiter drauf eingehen aber machen was
wir wollten jetzt sicher nicht sagt von
charlie wi schreibt ich hatte
wenn jungs hosen anhaben die bis zu den
kniekehlen geben
ok ich sage erst mal nur okay also wird
zu den krieg ist natürlich jetzt ein
bisschen überspitzt dargestellt
ich meine wer trägt eine hose in den
kniekehlen aber ein bisschen weiter
runter so ein bisschen nett ich muss man
jedoch tragen
ich meine mich stellt euch mal vor ihr
ich ziehe meine hose so übels hoch ich
habe zwar eine jogginghose an aber ist
egal
doch scheiß außen und ich meine wenn ich
dir ein bisschen locker locker lässt
sich herunter hängen so ich bin schon
dass es dann so ein bisschen cooler aus
sind einfach nur klar wenn ich jetzt
hier nur weit unten hab dann ist das
wieder was anderes feature und jetzt
dieses teil habe ich und wenn ich nicht
so lang kann wirklich dieses video habe
ich kann einfach meine hose ausgezogen
vom band und der letzte kommentar von
eving und unstet die obsession ver.di
die obsession also hallo alex und ihre
ein neues lieblingswort von doc ist das
gop leute software etwa dazu wie schon
gesagt bei 13 1737 leichter so gibt es
an diesem part zehn mädchen und jungs
gräfin schönfeldt aktiv im leben war
immer zweck bei instagram ab wie schon
gesagt ist in der wiederbestellung
verlinkt oder einfach alexander v alex
wie mich freuen wenn er da mal
vorbeischaut bei meinem neuen pick und
schreibt doch einfach mal drunter wird
dazu gefällt ansonsten freitag um 14 uhr
wieder und da werden wir ein paar
süßigkeiten gebrutzelt ich habe bock
drauf das ganze durch morgen und mal
sehen freitag zurück haut rein captured
könnte ich mir auch gern vor